[Music]
look master okay we think that we're
heading in the right direction so we're
just looking for the right entrance
there are lots of attention at the
entrance d.c be I'm actually more
interested in the cafe had a master
someone
it looks pretty grand so we've just
registered we've got our passport things
fan is going to be meeting people oh my
gosh and we're off to the auditorium for
the first panel maybe here yeah first
means someone whoever they I could be
making a film with them is don't get
your camera out when you meet them first
of all I just want to say really enjoy
the panel it was great discussion guys
on a level your videos I do have a
question for dr. Harun specifically the
first panel done the side panel was
kneelin non-scientist review I was
really interesting actually it certainly
didn't feel like it was only aimed at
those
to a super-interested a in science
scientific imagination you know like
maybe sorry very much humanities made
about production not very likely find
specifically yeah that's really really
interesting and you know Hank was a
great moderator it's also the first time
I've seen both hand carry IRL yeah like
seeing them in the flesh is a little bit
disorienting because I was looking at
the screen I was like wait go with use
head he's dead yeah
okay so um for carefully no Sally and I
have stopped as soon as I hit I hadn't
given full access which means I am in
the inner sanctum this is where all the
big youtubers who are at VidCon hanging
out I just had a lovely chat with trans
cream I've just bumped into the man
himself
look this is mrs. Hank green hi this is
you're the reason this is all happening
I mean a lot there are a lot of reasons
how are you gonna get done so great I'm
really happy
I've had a great town yeah it was really
good a really really really enjoyed I
got lots of questions you got a question
yesterday I got this in my change clown
and you'll know that it looks a lot like
a two euro coin but here the coins off
the but this is just going from Thailand
oh so I got I got exactly two euros
stolen from me by a grocery store well
you go on up to now as a meeting we're
talking about your anime trash person
other languages oh no I made a comment
session
but my heart is beating about centipedes
a minute right now I am freaking out my
peoples are like wide open this is all
[Music]
I'd like to point out by the way I felt
like such a dinosaur because I even
recognized after the achievement here I
mean I'm really interested in the
science theory we just saw but I want a
big magazine Jan is now going to sign
the ball but there's a slight problem he
can't reach the light space go away joy
give you a leg up
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean if anyone's going to get
roughly like aging probably me
they'll be neighbors you know so don't I
are about to joining gladiatorial combat
testing our leg muscles against each
other in the Bungie Conroy it sounds
like listen today when you said out loud
[Music]
the VidCon is full of famous people
getting recognized by fans but for one
I've also got recognized this is Wendy
just Soho dad did you see what that I
would just do yeah
it's really fun yeah we did look kind of
stupid though we know actually that dumb
in real life how are you planning to
come great it's a lot of fun
okay so I've got a lot of times I'm now
going to actually create a language
which is what I can do because partly on
this youtuber so that was me walking
along the path to the crater lounge
what's that I can hear it's a leader
page Wow okay I'm brandy lengths
substrates the first creator tracking
list the trace camel allows rising
business say riot rising YouTube channel
like stories and how they've risen up
through the ranks
I'm pleased right Wow I'm even whiter
than normal
I'm smoothly I make marketing videos and
I have 10 million so it's a tremendous
honor to be invited on a panel at VidCon
it's an even bigger honor to just be
spontaneously invited up into the
audience
Brian how did that go for you I'm great
still in bed asleep I messaged him
actually I was going on my channel I
can't even include the reply is it he
wasn't best pleased and found out that
missed out the chance going to safe with
Hank green that's out of context Brian
and I are going to be doing a beer more
are we doing a bit much pain I'm going
to see like we air I feel like we got
back out there
[Music]
Oh Robin X we are competing we met her
on the spot
Tom we met you on the from Tijeras form
in a very little as well done on a scale
of one to ten how much do you enjoy
Dodi's content
on a scale of one to ten probably a
singer and a specimen yeah
dun dun is a big fan of what you do
don't eat now so it's just worth
noticing okay I'm going to start round
here it's not just entertaining but what
is spoken about and how it's and the
manner in which spoken is so important
and in certain timing as well as dialect
yes such an ambassador for the path
anyway that's me I'm done I don't know
because then this happened it was going
quite well I thought I'm maintaining
quite a bit of composure we're doing the
right thing in mind I'm kind of
surrounded by girls between the ages
the angles so
they was dying to investigate
anyway I get to second class new life
you are yeah
no problem it goes all right excuse a
bit weeping summer is making me stop and
go am I to say you'll leave me any
for some reasons that you'll being down
like finally I'm just feeling it bring
me alone man forget suddenly as she
looked at me and I smiled I completely
completely I have no idea I have a phone
out okay don't have time okay so it
didn't get my phone was in and tumbled
around for a bear County now I think
they've got five hi and then she
eventually cleared are we wearing and
that was like truth Frank comes back
point I just I can't I don't know how to
watch by sensory
10 cents would you mind if you took
selfies I don't trust myself to take a
selfie
I genuinely thought
I see
you got
but it was just the most I wouldn't have
any other way the entire education
melted down I did you know the scene and
the crikey crikey go strike is amazing
you
oh yeah Masek you mean
can you reenact what your last sentence
to go discount do you try to step so I
start by saying so and I just want to
say this video that you made
three importantly I think about that
farm thank you very much
clearly the enhancement open I kind of
when I see you I and interesting my
mouth kind of work for a little bit and
kind of stick miles I files i unless
if duty if you're watching it it's
honest and he was so sorry I'm so so
sorry he's a master pan he was sorry
tied to you
we're not be normal people we are the
way she talks left alone
happening today which is how much I'm
not funny person I'm not very long
I'm the best after here are many great
but is that I just do my consent
thank you dude they're like seriously
five minutes now wrong I'll open the
city for a few hundred and okay is the
big much English
[Music]
right happy right right right so we just
left the live show a little bit early so
you could drop some stuff off at the air
B&B that was amazing oh my god we just
watched Carrie hope Fletcher nail new
direction from the other family that was
true under spoken word by Spanish out
around yeah
as always absolutely on point really
really good I mean that that show
generally was start on a bit of a
strange note but very very enjoyable oh
yeah yeah
how has your first day of VidCon bins
done Lucy Club Simon how's your first
day I'm pretty groovy done yeah how's it
been groovy yeah three days all around
so we're here at the tea party today
kyu-jong coming in
and buddy we have another category those
communicator channels down there
your pig night so I smell Lilly is not
like this okay so down and I just got
back it is gone midnight I had actually
had dinner yet so we just stopped off at
a junk food place
Oh realizing that I really like I just
got some chips because there's not much
that's vegetarian that has got swarmer
Slama sure yeah it's like a kebab but I
think unlike a kebab it's like a it's a
solid thing of meat rather than several
bit have you ever had one before no does
your entire knowledge of chuan come from
the emceeing the Avengers
yes he asked his knowledge of garlic
sauce do it I responded yes he also that
he Steve he said of course garlic sauce
garlic sauce oh so nice tiger
yeah garlic sauce yes hot no they just
spicy oh yo and ya know it was the fact
you might yeah but he thought about yeah
you know cou well I say he's look good
oh my I cannot identify what meat that
is we haven't seen many stray animal
grass stuff really the whole point is it
across sexes you go across the whole
thing
yeah but if I go across point let's jump
into it though we might have to eat a
Farkas Spectator I've got my chips for
them
that's breathable you've got sort of
time refers everything that quakes quite
spicy yeah your graphing asking for I
think yeah do you want to drink so hot
you could only knows kallu there we go
that's better
spice factories through the roof and it
is very very spicy overall overall but a
54.1 fam bossman had it going on when I
did everyone thought smell like this lot
and I'm like this is kickboxing boxing
team that botany turn done yeah it's
this racist
[Music]